[Music]
so last time we spoke we were supposed
so excited for Comic Con
yeah and now here we are San Diego
comic-con indeed how is it been to come
back now that the shows into the second
season other things have evolved it's
the bet I mean it this year has been the
best so far like and I say that every
year cuz comic-con is great but it's so
nice to see that the fanbase is here and
we have some wonderful fan base and
everyone's been so lovely and it's truly
it's really an amazing thing yeah and
the show's escalated tremendously yes
very much
and has the response from the fandom
been like I can't imagine people aren't
excited to see these characters they've
always loved yeah that change no I think
the thing is it season two in so many
ways is a beautiful evolution of what
season one was so the what we've seen is
actually that you know the old fans
coming back saying this show is so far
evolved what it was and I love the first
season but the second season is so much
better yeah and then we have new viewers
coming inside like I binge watch the
whole first season I couldn't wait to be
here for season two and it's been really
really great he's been wonderful to see
hell ya know it's also we talked about
our Shakespearean it was yeah the depth
of the characters really fleshed
themselves out and the show allows hours
and hours to dive in how was your
process with the character change has
anything surprised you that you
discovered coming back to play you know
it was such a wonderful guy keep saying
his wonderful evolution of that
character because in season 1 he was so
often on the backfoot he was so often
trying to shirk his responsibilities as
a hero he didn't he didn't want that
position and he in season 2 has
discovered what it is to be a hero he
understands the importance of the
mission and in so many ways he comes out
of the Phantom Zone more sure than ever
of who he is and that's been wonderful
to play because it's sort of the version
of the character I always wanted to play
yeah and he has so much agency over his
his choices now and the wonderful thing
is now that when he's challenged you
know Episode six was just add you know
we see the ramifications of light is
death in season one he would've gone
like that's it I got a kill everyone and
I'm going to have a crazy revenge
rampage that's not who he is anymore so
we need to we need to try and press for
as best we can there will be a time to
mourn light it but it's not now yeah and
I feel like the the character finding
himself allows you to find a new himself
like a new yeah a new take on
his outer shell very much so very much
so and especially countering that with
Zod and how sure of himself he is has
that changed your relationship in those
scenes do you reframe how dialogue
bounces off him and back and forth it's
it's a wonderful thing to see because
before it was almost ironically a sort
of father-son relationship in that said
kind of found a father figure in this
man that that he all throughout season
one was constantly looking for someone
to give the responsibility to and he
sees this man who is brave and strong
and has a plan and he says yeah and I'll
follow you
and now he comes out of hands and more
sure of himself and of course he and
General Zod both have that experience in
common of being in the Phantom Zone yeah
so now they more talk to each other as
equals and there as much as they're on
the opposite side there's a huge amount
of respect there and playing those
scenes that Colin is so wonderful cuz
it's so loaded yeah he he described as
odd as a like a fallen angel
it was such a beautiful metaphor and how
do you see season 1 versus season 2 for
your character do you feel like he's
reached a different kind of metaphorical
state of beings there's such different
characters almost yeah I pose phantoms
very much so I think I think that season
1seg was a young man the he he was lost
he was sort of the outsider and in
season two I think he still doesn't see
himself as a hero or a leader but he
understands what it is to be one and
he's someone who's willing to do his but
I think he's still the beautiful thing
about the character is that he's just a
guy but when he's called upon he'll do
the job
yeah and he you know it's it's sort of
the thing if it used to be like you know
I don't want to do that now I was like
all right okay yes all right then let's
go you know there's something wonderful
about playing that so there's a real it
makes him a hero that's yeah he's still
he's still the constant underdog which
is always a joy to play now playing the
character as an underdog and then
knowing you're the grandfather of the
ultimate not underdog Superman is such
an above us creature he's supposed to be
we look up to and I feel literal and and
I love the idea that you come from a
grounded place to make Superman more
grounded in hindsight when you think of
Superman now that you've lived in this
role for two years
do you see Superman differently when you
read a book do when you when you see
another adaptation you know that the
wonderful thing about
and also about Adam as well is that Adam
is unable to communicate the miracle of
Superman 2 SEC so said really has no
idea who this guy is he's no idea what
he looks like you know he doesn't have
any concept of who this person is other
than that he's an incredible person who
saved a lot of lives and and so
wonderfully forsake Superman is an ideal
yeah that sort of is is vague and it's a
wonderful idea more than is a real thing
and what that means for me is that I
don't really have to worry about sex
view of Superman when I'm reading the
books right it's sort of great so you
and sexy Superman the same way because
of how Aziz interpreted in the show as
well as in your life yeah very much also
things I've very specific ideas about
who Superman is because I've read so
many of the books and I know who he is
to me
who used to sag is so it could be
anything yeah it just doesn't seem real
to him so I've watched most superhero
shows most superhero movies and I got to
say you were responsible for maybe one
of my favorite Easter eggs on the thirty
years this man loaded his arms yeah can
recap I did I did I was the happy I'll
act cheered it was a whole thing yeah
what was the impetus how did that come
to be well I knew that I knew that Lobo
and I were gonna throw down and it was
just like you have to who's mission
impossible I don't know if it'd just
come out when we were filming it or the
trailer just come out something like
that but everyone was talking about it
was the thing that went viral and
basically I think I think I just had the
idea to throw it in there because in
season 1 I did the George Reeves wink
and I think that's the beautiful thing
is that season 2 for us was so much
about embracing our comic book roots
saying like hey we're proud to be a
Superman show and this is the world in
which superpowers and aliens and
monsters exist so let's just go for it
and I think the beautiful thing about
comic books we talked about before is
that it's all about passing on the story
it's about leaving it better than you
found it but also there's a fantastic
legacy of storytellers that have come
before us and so if you can pay tribute
to them then why not do it especially if
it's something just fun yeah and it was
it was a great I mean my favorite pieces
of marketing yeah I want to see the show
because of how much they care yeah oh
yeah absolutely you know it's so much
fun and I think Henry Cavill as as a
force as superb
is really reflected in the show now and
I do like the wink and I do like these
things
is there anything long-term you see as
leading seg towards like is there any
Superman ideal that you want to slowly
evolve into your character that's a very
good question I I think I think it's for
SAG I think it's it's it's learning that
the beautiful thing about Superman is
that to Clark Kent Superman is also an
ideal is that he isn't Superman he isn't
perfect he's always trying to do the
right thing he doesn't always know the
right thing but he's always trying to do
the right thing and being Superman
allows him to be something more than
what he is yeah and I think I would love
segued to learn that that enjoy it a bit
more Superman loves being Superman yeah
and I would love to see seg learn that
lesson it's like you know what this is
actually this is a great thing for me to
like being a hero isn't all about
sacrifice and pain and it's about small
moments and it's about doing good things
it's about kindness and for sake so
often his is his struggles of a world
ending and the stakes are so high and so
often the best Superman moments is just
him you're helping a lost child finds
mom yeah you know so I would love to see
sag learn things like that just being a
hero can be small as well I like that
and I definitely said as a Kryptonian
learning curve like oh yes that's a
running theme and Kryptonians of like
finding a kitten in a tree is just as
important sometimes oh yeah hey like if
you if you help a lost kid finest mom
you're saving the world for that kid
right you know and I love that
perspective is there anything you as a
comic book fan have enjoyed this
comic-con now there were no switch gears
in the comic-con yeah absolutely
cuz we're here and I feel like you and I
have great conversation about comics
themselves oh yeah and this is this is
we like we talked about it summer camp
oh yeah it's a real that we get to
experience this as fans would also work
yeah it's huge it's it's wonderful like
I love comic-con every year because it
you know I'm a very very live been a
very lonely nerd for most of my life and
now that I'm here and I'm a part of it
and people care what I think about comic
books I've been saving up conversations
that I've had one time to have four
years yeah so for me the thing I enjoy
most is just seeing my friends who
actually work on comics you know these
are people who I I was a fan of just
just growing up I love their books and
you know I met Frank Miller today too
that was wild that was Frank Melissa
I love your show that's like come on I
had the similar Thursday morning Tom
King introduced me to Frank Miller we
talked about Superman's yeah like
translation and how he appeals to each
of them separately and Batman and it was
yeah only happen here oh yeah no it's so
wonderful it's it's it's the real world
Justice League yeah it's incredible and
to see people walking around and having
the the adoration of fans that they're
so deserved like yeah I think artists
should be revered like the Pope I agree
I don't come here to hang out with film
stars yeah they got everything else yeah
this is about comic books and this is
about the legacy of what comic-con is
I'm especially you're 50/50 absolutely
yeah maybe I'm wrong but this feels more
like a comic-con to me than the last few
years have yeah this is something
special it really really feels like
something special for sure
have you been reading anything you want
to talk about that you feels like a good
gosh picking up speaking of Tom King
I've been I've been waiting for a very
long time for mr. miracle to be a
collected edition yeah I've now finally
had time to sit down start reading and
his absolutely genius
similarly Harrison crisis has just
finished yeah I was truly excellent and
I always read the Superman titles I love
what Ben this is doing with Superman I'm
so excited for his legion book with John
hen which i think is great
the Wonder Comics line I think is
absolutely spectacular Naomi dial 8 for
hero love justice like young those
characters were what got me into comic
books yeah so to see them sort of have
such a wonderful rebirth and I use that
word intentionally Jenny hex is lovely a
new character I love that Naomi
especially when Naomi lands is such a
part of the universe in such a unique
way and yeah he finds these back doors
introduce characters a hundred percent
also deceased yeah I adore Tom Taylor
both as a writer and as a human being
he's a wonderful person but he writes
such tragic horrible books and he's the
nicest guy he and like talk funny and
his new sister but that's the thing
about a lot about injustice is is that
it's undoubtedly one of the most tragic
comic books I've ever read also one of
the funniest
yeah there's a wonderful sense of humor
too at all and you know to anyone who
doesn't think they might not like he
thinks it might not like the DC Universe
give him justice a Gohonzon justice is
such a great book in fact like Tom
Taylor Tom King and Bendis are all the
best like gateway drugs into DC right
now yeah yeah for sure and they'll catch
you up really quickly here
like what's issue 78 like yep you're
there yeah I love I love I love creators
as well you know that perhaps a little
bit more of an advance read but but
Grant Morrison and Geoff Johns and
people who are like you know the
continuity at at a certain point yes
absolutely a barrier to entry because
there's so much of it but also I think I
love those writers who say like no this
is a really cool thing yeah unless let's
use the Batman of 0nr as a really cool
plot device it's a really full story
device and I that because as you know
comic books are always about rebirth
it's always about finding where to tell
the next story and very often it's going
back to seeing you know the genesis of
an idea it comes from back there and you
bring it forward into a new light in a
new era and I love that well I think the
archetype especially of DC characters
and I love both houses but I think DC
characters have this beautiful archetype
that a writer can find a totally
different angle because it's such a
perfectly formed sphere yeah you find a
little circle that hasn't been touched
yet you dive into that very much so and
it's beautiful to see new writers
especially like Tom Taylor I know from
Marvel but what he's doing a deceased
I'm getting a new perspective 100% and
I'm the same way I've always been more
of a DC guy but purely for that reason
is that it all felt more connected to me
that the whole DC universe expands out
from the Justice League and that you can
see the relationships between the teams
between the characters very very clearly
whereas with Marvel I adored individual
characters I adored the x-men I adored
Incredible Hulk I loved spider-man yeah
you know but it felt much more like
episodic storytelling as opposed to a
cohesive universe have you touched Tom
Taylor's friendly neighborhood
spider-man yet no I need to get into it
yeah like an actual neighborhood book to
the point you meet his neighbors Oh
grounded so contained oh I bet Tom's
brilliant as anyway you're right Spidey
like you can just flip eNOS the speed
the flavor and like the the artist on it
is photorealistic but still like high
jinks II yes the perfect so like right
now I think is one of the most Golden
Age of comics we've had since I was I
was saying this to a friend of mine is
it like yes it's amazing we have all of
these movies and the TV shows and the
people loved it in the mainstream in the
way that they never had before but
really the comic books themselves are
better than they've ever been totally
agree you know mr. miracle is a great
example I don't I think that hardcover
or or the trade either way like The
Collected mr. miracle is one of the best
books to show someone that thinks they
don't like comics a hundred percent well
that's the beautiful thing about the
medium is like if you think you don't
like comic books you're wrong
there is a comic book out there for
everyone yeah that's like saying you
don't like food yeah I'm trying to write
food yeah you haven't found the right
yeah absolutely
yeah so fine find the right food for
yourself and also check out Krypton
because it is finding the archetype of
Superman in a way that I never thought
would work we talked about it before I
just I didn't think going back in time
would make me appreciate the president
as much as it has and the show is
magnificent and congratulations it's
it's so good
appreciate that always a pleasure
talking to you man take it